i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks
using my link below
before we get into uh the meat of
today's show i want to briefly address
something here at the top
that relates to something we've been
talking about for years about what makes
it into the corporate media narrative
and what doesn't and one of the things
i've told you many times before
is that stories with a good beginning
middle and end a clear beginning middle
and end are much more likely to be made
stories by corporate media and so for
example when we talk about shootings a
particular shooting where we have the
shooting is going on
they've captured or killed the shooter
what's the back story on the shooter
thoughts and prayers are sent the
victims boom that it's done okay
the bigger story of the constant and i
mean almost daily mass shootings in the
united states more than daily in fact
is less of a story because it's an
ongoing story it doesn't have a very
clear beginning middle and end and i can
think of no greater illustration of this
than the fact that since the shooting in
uvalde texas last week since
there have been 17 mass shootings in the
united states 17 more shootings
since the uvalde texas shooting you can
read about them if it's
uh you know it is it is depressing
reading you can read about them at
gunviolencearchive.org
and you will see that for example over
the weekend in philly there was a mass
shooting where two people were killed
and two people were injured
in henderson nevada seven were injured
in a mass shooting in phoenix arizona
there was a mass shooting when one
person was killed and five people were
injured and you can just look at the
list and as i've said before every
single one of these is its own story
um you know you could look at the
henderson nevada shooting for example
and it pops up
a facebook page or it will eventually uh
from the henderson police department
explaining what happened and uh there
was a reported shooting and police and
fire responded and on and on and on
every single one of these is a story and
it is a constant and that's why it's not
as big of a media story individually
any of these might make news or they
might not
most of them have at least like a local
news article that's written about it but
consider everything that's happened in
uvalde texas
learning about the shooter and what
happened and how they got in and on and
on the victims the morning
there have been 17 more such incidents
with victims and perpetrators and police
responses and affected families etc 17
of them since uvalde most of us only the
mo for most of us the last shooting we
really heard about was the one in uvalde
texas so
it's a it's a story with seemingly no
end and that doesn't make it a good
corporate media story but it continues
to happen almost or even more than
once every single day
we are not yet able to say
that the dam is breaking when it comes
to republicans and gun safety
regulations in fact it's not breaking in
total but we are starting to see some
cracks as multiple republicans including
an nra endorsed republican are now doing
a 180 and saying it's time for gun
safety regulations something has to be
done i have two examples of that for you
we're first going to look at an
interview that republican congressman
adam kinzinger did on cnn now caveats
adam kinzinger is leaving congress okay
adam kinzinger is not a trump republican
he is an anti-trump republican and so
some people will write him off and say
he's not really a republican because of
that but this is a republican who for a
long time opposed banning assault style
rifles
and now he said it's something he's open
to this is a major change take a look at
this congressman you do still oppose a
ban on the kind of assault weapons that
were used in the shooting can you
explain why private citizens need
weapons of war
look i have opposed a ban uh you know
fairly recently i think i'm open to a
band now that's gonna depend what it
looks like because there's a lot of
nuances on what constitutes you know
certain things but i'm getting to the
point where i have to wonder maybe it's
maybe somebody to own one maybe you need
an extra license maybe you need extra
training
and so the question is is it a band
versus an additional certification but
yeah i gotta tell you i mean the 99.9 of
people that own ars we all know are not
going to walk into a school and do this
but the problem is for those that
support the second amendment like me
we have to be coming to the table with
ways to mitigate 18 year olds buying
these guns and walking into schools my
side's not doing that right my side's
not coming forward with reasonable ways
to defend an amendment that we think is
very important and so i'm looking at
this going fine if people are going to
put forward solutions about certifying
maybe who can buy an assault weapon
i'm certainly open to that so listen
it's no big gun safety declaration
he's leaving congress he's saying maybe
it's just more restrictions and not
really banning them but it's a change
and it's an important change now the
reality is that a ban alone isn't enough
to really interrupt the school shooting
fiasco we have in this country but it's
maybe one part and i talked about that
in my list list of 10 specific gun
safety proposals that i outlined last
week it's also important to mention
kinzinger still voted with trump 90 of
the time while trump was president um
but listen he's willing here okay and so
let's let's praise it for what it is and
not go overboard now here's another
example then chris jacobs who's a
straight-up
nra endorsed congressman from new york
after the buffalo shooting he also says
that his perspective has changed there's
a great piece in the buffalo news
which says
congressman chris jacobs of orchard park
made a surprising about face on gun
control issues becoming perhaps the
first congressional republican
to call for an assault weapons ban in
the wake of the recent mass shootings in
buffalo and duvalde texas at a news
conference and later with the buffalo
news jacobs who was endorsed by the nra
in 2020 laid out a series of new stances
that run contrary to the republican
party line on guns in addition to saying
he would vote for a democratic bill
banning assault weapons he also said he
would back raising the age on some gun
purchases to 21 my suggestion was 25 but
20 21 is something limiting the capacity
of magazines i agree and banning the
sale of military-style body armor to
civilians in the interview jacob said
the two recent shootings forced him to
re-evaluate his position on guns and to
research where he wanted to stand in the
future
so what can we say
i can't say the dam is breaking
the nra is incredibly strong but there
are cracks starting to form and it
really remains to be seen
whether this will
uh become anything and whether anything
will happen or not
this could start to achieve change or at
least start putting pressure on people
to make a change and it's very
interesting adam kinzinger chris jacobs
let's see who else had themselves to the
list the claim in washington is that
this is different
now we've heard that a thousand times
before because we've had a thousand or
more mass shootings um
but uh it remains to be seen whether
that will be the case i have some
incredible video for you today it would
be funny if it weren't so scary
cnn's jim acosta while the nra
convention was happening in houston
texas in the same state were 72 hours
earlier we had this horrific shooting in
uvalde texas cnn's jim acosta
interviewed a board member of the
national rifle association that board
member is a republican judge named
phillip journey
also a former kansas state senator
jim acosta asked why should an 18 year
old be able to have an ar-15 why does an
18 year old need an ar-15
and again it would be hilarious if it
weren't for the fact that these people
and this organization were so powerful
take a look at this historic implosion
on live television
with these mass shootings it keeps
coming back to the it keeps coming back
to the ar-15 and similar models
why do people need an ar-15 anyway
you know it's just a semi-automatic
rifle i mean you know if you want to be
prejudiced about the way it looks
but i was aware of what happened in the
94
semi-automatic firearms ban and there
were rifles of similar function that
just didn't look as ugly they weren't
black guns like a mini 14 ruger mini 14.
so i i i can't help but mention
this talking point about there's
prejudice against certain prejudice
against certain weapons based on how
they look
they want to almost make it like it's a
form of racism like you're judging
things by their cover and that you're
you're prejudiced if you look at a
weapon and say that's a bad weapon
they want to use the same terms almost
as if it were a form of racism this is a
concerted effort that they make to talk
about prejudice and discrimination
against firearms based on the way they
look okay let's continue the meaningless
word salad and of course the ruger mini
14 was appropriate and the ar-15 was not
if it had a bayonet lug or a vertical
rear grip
so they designed i do want to ask you
about the assault weapons ban but you
know on the ar-15 how how is it that an
18 year old can buy an ar-15 style rifle
and have 1600 rounds of ammo with him
like we saw in uvalde
well it's he did not have any prior
convictions he didn't have any prior
issues that would have kept him from
purchasing one it's my understanding
from the news that he purchased it
through a firearms dealer he passed a
background check because he didn't have
any prior convictions now of course this
is the problem if we did the things i
suggested
limit these firearms to those 25 plus
require more extensive training require
two or three letters from adults in the
community saying i have no issues with
this individual having firearms require
a mental health evaluation
those things
would likely have at least made it more
difficult for these for this individual
to get these particular firearms what
this guy's saying is
he got him because there was nothing in
place that stopped him right well but
that's the problem we need to put things
in place
right but should an 18 year old have an
ar that's how he bought it should an a
should an 18 year old have an ar-15
what's he going to do i don't know an 18
year old have one in the army
so they had military they had military
training in the army this 18 year old in
uvalde did not have military training he
turned 18 and he went out bought an
ar-15
okay and the fact is that these kinds of
issues did you just call them ed
are far more complicated than whether we
remove something from the public
these issues in criminogenics you can't
buy a beer if you're 18. you can't buy a
pack of cigarettes like crime are more
complicated than than the easy answer
do you want to know why politicians
seems to go to gun control because it
doesn't cost them any money oh god uh
okay so listen completely humiliating i
mean a complete and total implosion
that being said the pro-gun people do
have an easy answer which this guy just
missed i don't agree with this answer
but sometimes you know when when you ask
some of these folks this exact question
that jim acosta is asking sometimes they
go
jim i don't need to defend it it's in
the constitution period now it's lame it
ignores reality but it is an answer
which is like just because you don't
like it jim doesn't mean it isn't in the
constitution it's not about why does an
18 year old need it we have a
constitution and a right to bear arms
now of course the counter would be
limiting certain guns for certain people
whether because of age or whatever these
are not violations of the second
amendment
um so there is uh
there are rebuttals to the rebuttals for
sure and this entire thing of your
prejudice against guns because of how
they look they want you to think like
it's racism now one bonus here as you
all may know and we will look at later
donald trump danced he did his dance on
stage after speaking to the nra three
days after the horrible shooting in
texas
jim acosta asked this guy this nra board
member
about trump's dancing and the guy just
denies that it happened and then cnn
puts it up on the screen alongside this
guy saying trump didn't dance and this
is what we've been talking about for a
long time
it doesn't matter if it's on video
they'll still deny stuff in uvalde your
group is holding its convention in
houston where you are right now just a
few days after the massacre in uvalde we
saw donald trump dancing on stage uh at
the end of his remarks uh he was not i
was there he was not dancing how was
how is any of this at all appropriate
we're showing it on stage right now he's
doing a little jig there
people are waving their nra hats and so
on it's this celebratory
atmosphere right after a mass shooting
where all of these kids are gunned down
how is that appropriate
i think that what you're doing is just
telling part of the story there because
at the beginning of his speech he did do
a very memorable memorial for the victim
so first he says trump didn't dance and
then when the video gets put on the
screen he says well the dancing is only
part of the story but but you just said
he didn't dance so which is it these
people are really sick really really
sick they are not a scourge as trump
pronounces it but they're they're really
a scourge
and uh we're going to look at what
happened at the nra convention after the
break but we've got an uphill battle
here my friends i do want to announce we
are going to be doing our next david
pakman show member town hall on june
14th at 6 p.m eastern it'll be streamed
on the pacman live youtube channel only
and i hope you'll join me there
one of the fastest growing crimes in the
u.s is identity theft and there's a new
victim every 14 seconds
this has happened to me before i've
talked on the show we got hacked it was
costly it wasn't a good feeling and
that's why i now protect myself with
aura one of our sponsors protecting your
accounts and devices gets complicated
because you need a bunch of different
tools and aura combines them all into
one app identity theft protection
fraud monitoring password management
antivirus all in one place they monitor
email addresses passwords social
security number bank accounts credit
cards if something happens you get an
immediate alert on your phone and then
aura can help me fix it as well aura is
letting my audience try it free for two
weeks at aura.com
pacman with the free trial you can do
things like see if your login
credentials have been found on the dark
web i saw an old password was in four
different data breaches
probably something you want to know and
it's free so you might as well just use
the link down below alright we are now
going to talk about the nra convention
which took place over the weekend it
took place not that far in the same
state of texas where the shooting
happened earlier the same week in uvalde
texas republican texas governor greg
abbott bailed on speaking there some
others bailed as well understandably it
looks absolutely terrible to go and
speak at the place that celebrates more
guns in more places right after this
horrifying mass shooting that took place
in uvalde but ted cruz insisted on
speaking and so did donald trump one of
the sickest and most dangerous events i
have ever seen we covered it live ted
cruz's speech was downright sinister
with the exact type of pablum and
apologia that you would expect
in the wake of a horrible gun disaster
at a speech for an organization that
just wants more guns in more places
trump's speech was even worse and one of
the most
vile
uh stunts that i've ever seen at any
event is trump quite literally did a
gong show
trump decided to read the names of the
victims of the uvalde texas shooting
many of them
very difficult for trump to pronounce of
course any stunt based on trump reading
names is risky we know what what
happened when he tried to read uh indian
the names of indian people
in india very bad idea and they ring a
gong after each one look look at this
sick political stunt of silence as i
read the names of these beautiful people
all young
wonderful lives ahead of them
they're brave teachers whose lives were
destroyed by an out of control
lunatic
so we'll start look at this
alexandria
rubio
i thought the gong was a joke at first i
thought it was somehow added as a joke
in the feed
alitha
ramirez
ann marie
garza
annabelle guadalupe
rodriguez
eliana
cruz
taurus
ellie
garcia
jacqueline cazares
i'm not even going to subject you to the
entire thing
but this is i mean it's it's sinister
the way that this is being used and what
it reminded me of is there's this very
controversial thing that has happened
historically in the mormon church
where after certain non-mormons die
the mormon church will baptize them
posthumously
into
the church of latter-day saints against
their will these are people who had no
interest of in in being part of the
mormon church
and it's sort of like this they're part
of us they're being posthumously thrown
into the cult after their deaths
this is sort of like a version of that
it's it's to to to pull these victims in
um into the political cult of the nra of
guns of trumpism or whatever
um it didn't get any better as the
speech continued trump talked about
hardening schools which is now the thing
that they're talking about um he
ultimately called for teachers to be
armed he also made up the term virtue
cycling trump clearly wanting to read
the term virtue signaling i guess he's
not familiar with it and he incorrectly
reads off the teleprompter which obama
was evil for using remember obama used
the prompter and correctly read off of
it and it was bad trump has a prompter
messes it up constantly never an issue
listen to this
[Applause]
how many more tragedies will it take
until they agree to set aside their
far-left political agenda and do what
is really needed and what actually works
this is not about virtue
cycling and signing this is about
blaming your enemies no we don't want to
do that this is about saving our
children's lives yes that's what we want
to do
surely we can all agree our school
should not be
the softest target our school should be
the single
hardest target in our country
[Applause]
[Music]
it's hard to believe anybody believes
this at this point why as part of a
comprehensive school safety plan it's
time to finally allow highly trained
teachers to safely and discreetly
concealed
carry
and we've talked before almost no
teachers actually want to do that and of
course it brings the added complexity
that if there's a shooter police show up
and they can't tell now there's multiple
people with guns shooting you think the
police are going to first stop and ask
questions excuse me who's the good guy
with the gun here so we we only shoot
the bad guy with the gun makes it
possible for imagine a student to even
uh overpower teachers and and take the
firearms it's absolutely and completely
bonkers um at another point trump
brought up a guy who i guess shot
a shooter in a church shot this guy shot
someone dead at some point and the guy
talks about how trump is actually still
his president
thank each and every one of you again
thank you president trump and you're
still my president
yeah
so as you can see there is this overlap
between
the maga cult
and uh
this this is a pastor so it's like
there's there's an overlap a venn
diagram of christian nationalists the
maga election cult and the gun nra
people i mean that's very loud applause
for a supposedly nonpartisan
organization that's just about gun
rights to something that's insane you're
still my president just does it doesn't
make any sense and then lastly trump
capping off the speech
with dancing on the stage as music
played
um he seemed to only do it a little bit
probably even trump realizing this might
look bad
if we have the second worst mass
shooting in the last 11 years since
sandy hook or 10 years and then i speak
at a pro-gun event talk about how great
guns are we certainly don't need to
restrict them
and then i dance after mispronouncing a
number of the names of the victims it
doesn't look particularly good
and maybe trump realizing that it's a
totally depraved and sick country and i
have never received so many emails from
people around the world with two main
emotions
uh
fear and just being horrified by what's
happening in the united states
but being simultaneously perplexed like
david what the hell's going on there's
another shooting
an 18 year old had assault rifles with
1600 rounds of ammunition
and there's another shooting
and republicans say give more guns to
teachers and trump shows up at the nra
and he dances like it's it's
simultaneously being horrified and being
perplexed at what's going on
and uh
i i what can i say to them they're
completely right this is only happening
here the in this entire package this
configuration of this cult and the
availability of guns and the existence
of a party like the republican party
it's only happening here and it's
absolutely horrifying now i wouldn't
normally do this to you but it is
particularly relevant based on what's
happened over the last week in the
shootings the day after speaking at the
nra in houston texas and dancing on
stage at the end of his speech donald
trump flew to wyoming and gave a
campaign speech in wyoming for the
republican challenger to liz cheney liz
cheney now for the maga cult is an enemy
because she acknowledges that donald
trump really lost the election um they
want to remove her they're primarying
her she's doing very well in the polls
she'll probably win
but trump flying up there to campaign
for it's funny
when trump campaigns for someone that
person is almost completely irrelevant i
don't even remember the woman's name i
think it's ed hageman or something like
that
and um this trump's brain appeared to
just break it his brain is broken it's
not functioning in this clip trump
explains
how
his kaffifi tweet i call it cobb fefe
was so big he's like bragging about the
fact
that a tweet that was literal nonsense
and unintelligible by a president which
has never been explained he's bragging
how it was his most popular tweet ever
this
the guy's brain is not functioning
i put out like this tweet i think it was
like on a saturday morning and i saw
something on television and i said
i believe obama
spied
on my campaign
okay
no i didn't think it was that big a deal
you know you put a head on a ball
three minutes later i get a call like my
phone goes crazy
sir
sir did you just say that
president obama spied in your campaign
yeah what's the big deal
sir
the wires are burning up i said really
after kofi it was the single biggest
tweet i ever did
kofi was bigger
but he's ignoring the fact that the
reason it was big is because it was a
red flag globally that the president has
lost his marbles and his brain is broken
after kofi which was world's number one
it was the biggest tweet i ever did and
i thought it was just going to be like
routine you know i'm throwing it out but
that's what i thought that's what i
heard and you know why it was such a big
deal because
we caught them
and they realized that we caught them
and it became a monster now understand
that uh obama was not caught spying on
trump's campaign none of this makes any
sense but trump is now bragging about
coffee um
this is not a functioning brain it's not
a functioning brain trump then says that
the way to stop the war in ukraine
is to take out the windmills now he
means wind farms he uses the term
windmills he also wrongly claims the
russian ruble is now at an all-time high
bad as they're doing and as much as
they're spending the ruble
is at an all-time high because they're
taking in so
much money why you want to stop the war
drive down the price
of oil drive down the price
of energy you want to stop it stop with
the windmills
that kill all your birds and destroy
your environment yeah they're called
wind farms and they don't destroy the
environment and they kill fewer birds
than the oil and gas industry but more
importantly trump says the ruble is at
an all-time high
uh the ruble is actually close to an
all-time low we're putting the price
chart up on the screen and as you can
see the ruble is actually very low now
revisionist history donald trump is now
calling it a so-called insurrection and
he is saying the idea that it was an
insurrection on january 6
is as fake as the russia probe which by
the way was very very real revision is
history and the crowd accepts it now you
look at the so-called word insurrection
january 6. what a lot of crap
what a lot of crime
and most of this country knows it and
you know who else knows that the
democrats it's another con job just like
russia russia russia this was made up
by hillary clinton and the democrats
a total
fake story now i don't know if he's
saying there that the russia story was
fake
or that the insurrection story is fake
and made up by hillary clinton he thinks
both are fake for sure and then bringing
out all of the greatest hits trump also
lying about the price of gas 87
per gallon gasoline think of that now
it's going to close to nine dollars
today
that's 87
nine dollars and of course all you have
to do is look at the official gas prices
and you see that when trump left office
it wasn't a dollar eighty seven it was
two dollars and forty two cents and now
it's four dollars and twenty one cents
it's much higher no doubt nobody denies
that it is not nine dollars so another
absolutely despicable event uh just a
little bonus clip here trump uh
struggling to pronounce the word
conservative we're going to
vote out this atrocious rhino
and we're going to replace her with a
conservative warrior from a place called
wyoming yeah it doesn't seem as though
that's going to happen liz cheney is
doing quite well i have i'm not a fan of
liz cheney's i'm just telling you what
it looks like it looks like this will
almost certainly
be another loss in donald trump's
endorsement record the man's brain is
broken my friends and we'll have these
clips on our instagram at david pakman
show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
one of the most notable differences
right now between the democratic and
republican parties outside of ideology
is that the republican party
not only isn't ashamed to nominate and
elect people who just can't think whose
brains really don't work
they almost seem proud of it in some
strange way and one such person is
radical republican congresswoman from
georgia marjorie taylor greene fresh off
the
primary wind that she had last week who
now has gaffed again using the term
peach tree dish
rather than petri dish now we'll get to
that and when i say she's gaffed again
i'll remind you at one point trying to
talk about some kind of
covid gestapo
using the term gazpacho which is of
course a cold spanish tomato soup
sometimes with a cucumber in it which i
think is a nice thing to add to gazpacho
okay take a listen to this not only do
we have the dc jail which is the dc
gulag but now we have nancy pelosi's
gazpacho police spying on members of
congress now some people speculated she
does this on purpose to get attention
no she doesn't there is absolutely no
evidence whatsoever that she has any
idea about the word gazpacho versus
gestapo it there is absolutely no reason
to think that well she's done it again
and this time she's talking about uh
fake meats
and she seems to think that fake meat is
grown not in a petri dish which is of
course you know a little uh plastic
uh
container
for uh holding cells bacteria whatever
um that it is a peach tree dish it's a
dish in which you put a tree that grows
peaches you have to accept the fact that
the government totally wants to provide
surveillance
on every part of your life they want to
know when you're eating they want to
know if you're eating a cheeseburger
which is very bad because bill gates
wants you to eat his fake meat that
grows in a peachtree dish a peachtree
dish you'll probably get a little zap
inside your body and let's say no no
don't eat a real cheeseburger you need
to eat the fake the fake burger the fake
meat from bill gates
okay
so it's just a gaff right i mean who
cares well it's actually much bigger
than just any individual gaff
these people can barely put together a
coherent thought and it doesn't matter
we have a political party we have a
members of a political party in this
country
that don't care about the fact that
their candidates can't think they can't
think
and they still vote for them in normal
countries these folks would not stand a
chance at being in positions of power
and they'll come back and say oh how
elitist david
you think only people who use real words
and can speak
and think a little bit should be able to
be into well
i'm not saying it should be illegal for
them to run what i'm saying is that a
sane country would never vote for these
people
look at what's going on with herschel
walker in the senate i we played these
clips last week but i'll include them
here because they're relevant
herschel walker is endorsed by trump
former football player won his senate
primary in georgia
essentially unopposed
he can't speak he can't think
okay here he was asked by cnn reporter
manu raju whether there should be any
new gun laws and his answer was what i
like to do is see it in everything and
stuff
that that's the whole answer
with cnn
are you do you support any new gun laws
in the wake of this texas shooting
do you support the new gun laws in the
wake of what i like to do but i like
doing [ __ ]
and uh and everything and stuff i like
to see it
he likes to see it and everything and
stuff then up the next day he appeared
on fox news and he said he would solve
school shootings with a department
that can look at young men
looking at young women
looking at social media that's the
solution see there is a person willing
that weapon you know kanekia able you
know and uh you know and that's the
problem that we have and i said what we
need to do is look into how we can stop
those things you know they talked about
doing a disinformation what about
getting a department that can look at
young men that's looking at uh women
that looking at uh just social media
what about doing that looking into
things like okay so that's his idea we
want to get a department that can look
at young men looking at women looking at
social media they cannot speak
they cannot think and it doesn't
dissuade republicans it doesn't dissuade
republicans and so the question becomes
how can you defeat a movement
whose
elected officials don't even have to
have a functioning brain
and that doesn't even dissuade the
voters it doesn't seem like reality
matters anymore and so how do you defeat
that i guess voter turnout on our side
but uh i mean listen that you we say
that every year and then there's always
like so-so voter turnout particularly in
midterms so i don't know i don't know
what to tell you
this is a very interesting
john voight the actor father of angelina
jolie
he has been a right-wing guy for a while
now pro-trump guy kind of a maga hero
jon voight has gone off script as far as
the maga people are concerned after the
uvalde texas shooting and is now saying
oh we need screening and we need testing
for people who are going to have
firearms this is absolutely fascinating
around election 2020
john voight said he thought that he and
donald trump were are in our greatest
fight since the civil war
uh he has uh you know he used to be kind
of like a moderate he supported jfk
and whatever but he's gone completely
off the rails more recently
conspiratorial stuff talking about uh
democratic propaganda with subliminal
messages that obama was a godlike figure
that he would be make america socialist
like john voigt went hard right and
pro-trump and all of a sudden
in the last few days uh two days ago
right after the uvalde texas shooting he
put out what i would argue are the
sanest words he would he has spoken in
years
going 180 from what the maga people
believe take a look at this sure that we
will never see this horror again in this
lifetime
we must identify every individual for
their credentials for their mental
capacity to bear arms right there should
be proper qualifications for gun
ownership and proper testing
one should only own a gun if they're
qualified and schooled
i stand with all i stand for freedom of
each soul's truths
i stand for god's truths i stand for one
to be condemned for evil doings now he
he still can't get away from this weird
conspiratorial religious speak he can't
even get away from that in this segment
but he's saying we need testing we need
evaluation we need licensing we need
training this is already more than
republicans are willing to concede
and that they must pay a price
may god watch overall
and bring comfort for this loss which
may never heal for each child was so
precious a gift
and gohan will call on jesus
to pray for these families
he loved you
yeah
so he's still a very wacky guy i'm not
going to deny that
but this is not going to uh put him in
the good graces of the trumpists that's
for sure but everything jon voight is
saying makes perfect sense
how do you buy over the weekend i spent
time looking at how do you get firearms
in switzerland people love to talk about
switzerland and guns how do you get guns
in a number of different countries
look at japan as an example in order to
get a gun in japan
you have to take a firearms class
and pass a written exam
that's only done three times a year so
it's not like oh i want a gun this
weekend i'll just go and do the thing
this weekend that's number one you've
got to get a doctor's note saying you're
mentally fit fit and have no history of
drug abuse you have to apply for a
permit to take live firing training that
can take a month to get
you have to meet with police and explain
why do you need a gun
you have to pass a review of your
criminal history gun possession record
employment involvement with organized
crime personal debt relationships with
friends family and neighbors you have to
apply for a gunpowder permit you then
have to take a one-day training class
and pass a firing test you've got to get
a certificate from a gun dealer
describing the firearm that you're
looking to get to to buy
then you've got a if you want a hunting
gun apply for a hunting license you have
to buy a gun safe and an ammunition
lopper locker that meets safety
regulations you then have to let police
come in and inspect that you actually
have the proper storage setup you pass
one more additional background review
and at that point you are given a permit
with which you can go and get your gun
you can still get a gun
but there is serious scrutiny of the
people that are looking to do it
many of those elements
are part of what i've laid out and i
have to tell you
all my liberal gun owning friends
are fine with everything on my list and
why wouldn't they be because their goal
isn't more guns in more places their
goal is we have a second amendment
different people might have different
reasons for wanting to have a firearm
which by the way might include that so
many right wingers have them
and i'm willing to go through a
difficult process
because it will make me feel better that
only people who really safely can have
firearms have them
it's uh
listen as far as john voigt goes it's
glad to see him talk a little sense it's
been about a decade of him not making
any sense unfortunately sadly
um
i don't know that any of those things i
mentioned last week or that john voigt
mentioned in his clip are going to
become a reality anytime soon but we are
seeing some cracks with a few
republicans saying okay
now it's too far
now we finally have to do something
we'll soon see whether they do
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com
david pakman show because of all the
things that are constantly going on in
the world and also because gay marriage
is now legal nationally in the united
states
sometimes it's easy to get the sense
that the old school violent homophobia
of like kill the gays is over in the
united states it is not over and i'm
going to play some video for you today
of a christian pastor in arlington texas
who wants gay people killed and is very
much against the pride parade there was
a city council meeting in arlington
texas the point of it was
let's hear comments about whatever is on
people's minds and uh this christian
pastor is very much against the pride
parade these exist all over the country
they're generally supportive of lgbt
rights uh pretty uncontroversial at this
point in time and this homophobic magga
preacher in arlington texas show up
shows up and says gays are an
abomination
they should be executed i mean listen
that's what god says so listen to this
that this is still very much a thing and
the the scariest part is you'll hear
people in the crowd going yep
right they agree with it according to
god we should hate pride
not celebrate it we should humble
ourselves as
virtually the whole room said that we
were a nation under god according to the
american flag and we were a state under
god if we're in the texas flag we should
humble ourselves to what the bible says
and not what the small minority here
that is bully would say amen
in june of 2020 mayor jeff williams
officially announced the acceptance of
pride month in june
for the city of arlington
but i don't understand why we'd
celebrate what used to be a crime not
long ago
yep you hear those people yep according
to the texas penal code
and section 21.
homosexual conduct a person commits an
offense if he engages in deviated sexual
intercourse with another individual of
the same sex in fact that is still on
the books today even though
lawrence versus texas overruled that in
2003
but god has already ruled that murder
adultery witchcraft rape bestiality and
homosexualities are crimes worthy of
capital punishment leviticus 2013 the
bible says a man also lied with mankind
as he life with a woman
both of them have committed an
abomination they shall surely be put to
death their blood shall be they should
be put to death and people in the crowd
say amen upon them romans 1 says that
men with men are worthy of death second
peter chapter two warns and says that in
turning the cities of sodom and gomorrah
to ashes condemned them with an
overthrow making them an example of
those that after should live ungodly and
deliver just what vex with the filthy
conversation it is 2022
and they're still talking about
death
for gay people you know back in 2008 i
would do interviews like this
where people would say this stuff but we
like to believe it's not going on
anymore and he kept going with the
homophobic stuff and the crowd kept
saying yep yep according to cdc
homosexual men are 230 times more likely
to get hiv than straight men i don't
know why we promote
disease and aids in our community
additionally according to this article
of self-reported crimes the lgbt have an
average of 20 to 150 children victims
and including they commit an average of
154 acts on their victims now here's the
thing they say that they love so much
but they hate children they hate
baptisms they hate christianity
so this is the the gays or pedophiles
thing which is like this is old school
homophobia now i know many of you will
say david you know
leviticus which they often cite
leviticus also says eating shrimp is an
abomination but they all eat shrimp
what's up with that and it's true if you
look at leviticus it does say that when
you eat from the waters whatsoever hath
fins and scales in the waters
them shall ye eat
and all that have not fins and scales
they shall be an abomination unto you
that's what leviticus says and you would
say well but how can they point to
leviticus for the anti-gay stuff but
then they ignore all these other parts
of leviticus they simply talk about the
new covenant they've they've figured it
out guys they have a response to this
they say no no no no no
uh we christians
we
have been promised the new covenant
which was instituted at the last supper
as part of the eucharist
and it replaces the dietary law
but it didn't replace the anti-gay parts
so they they've got an answer for that i
know you and i would look at it and we
would say how hypocritical they'll be
picking and choosing but no and in fact
they won't just cite leviticus for the
anti-gay stuff they'll talk about what's
in timothy and what's in corinthians and
on and on and on from the new testament
so i know that it doesn't make any sense
it's hypocrisy it's picking and choosing
it's all this stuff that we're very used
to uh but at the same time at the same
time
uh they are continuing even though it's
2022. horrifying stuff all right now i
know that this is not the most important
story going on right now but i did want
to take a little break from just the the
heavy politics stuff we've been doing
for a bit and let you know about
something new that's going on as many of
you know we have struggled at the show
over time on different platforms we've
had uh 99.8 demonetization on youtube
during adpocalypse 1.0 about 60 percent
demonetization monetization on youtube
during adpocalypse 2.0 if you don't
remember these incidents the details are
less important than knowing that at any
point there are problems on different
platforms on tick tock we have had
suspensions for
so-called
covet disinformation which was us
debunking covet disinformation we had a
period of about three weeks where we
lost all of our revenue on facebook for
wrongly being labeled covet
disinformation okay we've had all these
different things
uh we are now experiencing similar
issues on instagram as many of you know
roughly a hundred thousand of you who
follow us on instagram we publish our
content to instagram it's another
platform with a ton of users and we want
to be there
we learned last week
that on instagram our account is being
limited
because of supposedly false content
about covid or vaccines that we have
disseminated and in fact for most users
if you try to mention david pakman show
which is us on instagram you get a
message which says can't mention david
pakman's show because they have
repeatedly posted content that goes
against community guidelines on false
content about covid19 or vaccines
what on earth how could this possibly be
i went and looked well what are the
clips that are supposedly
false information about covid or
vaccines there's only two such clips
that were removed
one is where we covered
that um
dr fauci
wanted a fox host fired over a kill shot
comment there was a fox host who talked
about fauci and used the phrase kill
shot which suggests violence against dr
fauci we covered that
and the clip was removed
the only other clip
that
we have had removed
by instagram is one in which we covered
uh we simply posted a um
a sort of political cartoon
about the reaction
to prior tragedies
um pearl harbor 911 and then the number
of people dying from covid which is well
well well higher
and how for many people there's no
reaction whatsoever that was also
removed and flagged as spreading coveted
disinformation it was actually saying
we're not taking covid nearly seriously
enough can you imagine
um
i looked up
what is the instagram policy
on condemning covid disinformation or
debunking coveted disinformation and
very clearly the policy is we allow
content shared
to condemn
or to debunk
we condemned a fox host using the term
kill shot talking about dr fauci we
condemned the lack of care from so many
in the united states about what at the
time was 3 200 people a day
dying of covid and we are now being
limited on instagram because we are
spreading covet or vaccine
disinformation now you would say well
there's got to be an appeals process
david you've got to be able to appeal
this there is but you can only appeal
this ruling if each of these decisions
has a case number attached to it which
ours do not so we quite literally cannot
appeal an insane decision now i know a
lot of people say oh but david this is
the censorship you've been advocating
for no it's not
that that's not true
i have been saying these companies can
have terms of service and if i agree to
the terms of service
and i abide by the terms of service
then there shouldn't be any issue the
terms of service are being misapplied we
obviously aren't spreading covet
disinformation or vaccine disinformation
so
if you work at meta facebook instagram
and you think you can help with this
please get in touch with us info
davidpakman.com i would very much
appreciate it when we had an issue on
facebook about a dozen people in the
audience who work at facebook got in
touch and we were able to get it
resolved it took almost a month but we
were able to get it resolved if you
think this is something you might be
able to help with please get in touch
info davidpakman.com
we just want to keep publishing our
stuff that that's all it's that we
clearly have been caught up in some kind
of dragnet that's that's more
conspiratorial than it is clearly some
kind of algorithm has misidentified our
content that's all and uh we would
appreciate help with that and of course
as always as we've said before
every revenue source we have other than
our website memberships has been cut at
some point in the past it's happened
with instagram facebook twitch of course
tick tock youtube all of it so the best
insulator for us so that when these
things happen they don't really affect
our revenues
is to get a membership on our website
joinpakman.com and you can do that uh
you can use the coupon code big voting
22
sort of a coupon code to encourage
voting and participation in the midterms
big voting 22
you can use that to sign up at
joinpakman.com
uh and it really it really does do a lot
and it helps to at least partially
protect us from when things like this
happen so let me know if you work at
meta facebook instagram info
davidpakman.com if you think you might
be able to help
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a very interesting voicemail now
i have spoken about this in the past
i've spoken before about a so-called
in-cell component to some of the mass
shootings okay some
here's a caller who is picking up on
something that may be true
i'm going to play it for you and then i
want to get your thoughts listen to this
hey david logan here i was just curious
about your opinion on something so it
seems like most the shooters that go
around and shoot up schools are mostly
sexually frustrated bullied young
individuals
do you think if prostitution was
legalized in america and certain
individuals could have access to certain
kinds of things do you think that might
have an impact on reducing the amount of
shootings in america i mean listen the
question is
if the shooters were having sex would
they not be shooters at the at the at
the fundamental core of the question
it's
that question
would having i mean really really it's
even more than that right it's not just
inability to find typically the shooters
are heterosexual male so i'll use the
term girlfriend although we could be
talking about a partner significant
other generally speaking
it does seem as though
a lot of these shooters are
not
establishing romantic relationships in
what might be a typical way given their
ages
and so the question fundamentally is if
they had a girlfriend or if they just
had more social connections would it
probably
reduce the number of shootings i think
the answer is it very well might
but what do you do about that
and regardless
should people who if they can't find a
girlfriend are going to shoot up a
school have access to guns like it
doesn't change the gun situation
but i think it's completely fair and
really it's responsible to say
this is such a complicated and major
issue
i talk about gun safety but we shouldn't
only be talking about guns
we
you know when the right says well we've
got to deal with mental health yeah
let's deal with it so you republicans
should stop voting against bills to
better fund access to mental health care
let's increase access to mental health
care in the country but let's also
require a psyche valve for having a gun
so maybe we can identify more people who
should be directed instead of to getting
a handgun or a rifle uh to a therapist
of some kind let's do all of the above
should we consider
you know not this whole eliminate all
doors but does it make sense to have
police do evaluations of schools and say
here's five recommendations that could
be done to increase security do it of
course do all those things but the guns
have to be a part of it and additionally
this element of well what is the the
connection between lack of social
connection lack of romantic
relationships and people doing these
things let's explore it anecdotally it
does seem as though this this is a
correlation factor
although the causation is much more
difficult to ascertain ascertain so
interesting voicemail many of you have
emailed in about essentially the same
issue we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today
joe biden is pointing to an assault
weapons ban
as a quote rational option for gun
control and gun safety we're going to
discuss it on the bonus show number two
um we have never been great at recycling
plastic and there are states trying a
new approach which we're going to
discuss on today's bonus show and in
addition the manager of the san
francisco giants
is um
taking a break
from his anthem protest
because of memorial day we're going to
talk about that we're going to talk
about what he's been doing gabe kepler
um and see what people think and much
more when i am joined by producer pat on
today's bonus show you can get access to
the bonus show by signing up at
joinpakman.com
alex jones doesn't want you to do this
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad yeah alex jones
in fact in fact finds everything i do
predatory that is a freaking predator he
doesn't like me but i recommend signing
up at joinpakman.com and you can use the
coupon code big voting 22
to get a sizable discount i will see you
on the bonus show in a moment or
otherwise back on tomorrow's program
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors i protect all of
my passwords accounts and devices using
aura i get instant alerts about threats
like if my email or password are found
on the dark web so i can fix the problem
fast try aura free for two weeks using
my link below